hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and i want
to talk about the end of this arc
because it's been a doozy and i half
don't think it's over but let's talk
about that i've certainly liked having
biscuit around and we know his key will
return so let's say a pluton farewell to
our favorite creepy kid and subscribe to
the idea that
hiskey will one day sport the ultimate
schwing let's get into episodes 74 and
75.
oh bomber gonna destroy gone silly man
can't destroy
con he's a steaming teenager there is no
one more stubborn or dangerous
while this was a great episode for the
fighting i couldn't help but think
gaureno's appearance
and the discussion that happened out of
it was tagashi saying
look the fighting part's over and i'm
bored because i like riding fights so
here
have the money and the cards and
everyone can have a car
out of this and level up and be
perfectly healthy
because why not you get a card and you
get a card
and you get a card cards for everyone
but especially our main characters who
managed to legitimately collect all the
cards we wanted them to collect
and you know what cards for the bad guys
everyone gets cards because now we know
everything about them and i suppose
to have gone back through all the cards
and read them all and understand what
they do i'm simply not sure how this is
going to play out i feel as though
they're going to be circled but that
everyone around them and true tagashi
i'm bored and i want this arc done now
style
we'll get them to all help because these
plebs don't know how to get out of the
game despite it being hunter grade
material
and thinking about that actually this is
supposed to be a game for hunters i
sound aggressive i know how
are so many of them basically useless
how have
so many of them clearly not been hunters
at all because they all have to be
able to use nem to complete the training
right and yet that's not what's happened
i know this has nothing to do with the
episode but since we're getting to the
end of an
arc it's close to the time where i
reflect on what the hell has happened so
far and why
every hunter within the game is
basically a weakling other than our
mains
i understand that that's the point the
aim is to shine a spotlight on the ones
we care about but still it just seems so
strange that we came into a game that's
supposed to be attempted by
generally stronger than average people
and they've just shown themselves to be
average
not even stronger than average just
average some of the people
bomber was killing were just average and
speaking of stronger than average what
happened to the black guy with the giant
snake creature he was snuggling up to
he just disappeared like piggy on an
airship tagashi's really not
very good at tying up lee sins but
enough of that why does gone keep losing
his left arm what's the deal with that
does he just hate it does his left arm
harm does his left arm offend him
somehow and why did gon
have to go on and go on to kick the dude
in the face it always entertains me that
his grand ideas are based on the concept
of hey
i can kick him instead of punching him
but i'm going to punch him because
that's fun too we all knew right that
bomber would lose but we didn't know how
and i'll be honest i really loved seeing
how they used the rock it's the only
part of the plan that was revealed
before it was being carried out and the
only proof we have or the only proof i
have i don't know about everyone else
the tagashi did actually have a plan in
place before he wrote it and while that
might seem like a strange thing for me
to say it's not actually that strange at
all i've mentioned the writing methods
of panting and planning before and while
it can be a mess to be a pantser someone
who flies by the seat of their pants to
write it can yield really creative
results
what i didn't know was how much planning
went into takashi's specific personal
pants style
losing track of snake guy and having
piggy turn up only to go back home or an
indication to me that he's a pantser but
the fact that he had a plan and that it
was actually a pretty ingenious one at
that suggests to me that he plans a
little more than i've given him credit
for
i suppose the whole card gamers quiz
show mechanic also requires planning but
that's something one could easily go
back in draft to and decide to add in
detail to the story because you need a
quick out by the end
it's the sort of thing i've done before
so there's no judgment just something i
notice and i'm well aware of
the fight though i know they're a hero
and villain speeches and i know that
they happen for a reason but i'm
surprised that palmer didn't just
continuously try to kill gone there was
more hesitance in his combat style with
gone than i expected to see from a
madman and despite his stated desire to
break gone
down i was somewhat surprised to feel
that he didn't actually want gone dead
at all
broken spiritually maybe but there was a
grudging appreciation for god's
abilities
the effect of this was strange to me
because the outcome was that he lost
some of his
madness i guess i mean by the end he was
terrified because he'd come up against
someone categorically more determined
ruthless and risk-taking than himself
and that was great
we saw the balance shift between them so
much that the bomber art we saw at the
end of last episode
reversed gone became an evil crazed
figure in the dark by the time we got to
the pitfall while bomber became more and
more stable
what's more while for gone nothing
changed from his perspective we saw
bomber come to that realization
almost in real time and that fear was
entirely understandable
how do you fight someone willing to
sacrifice both their hands without
concern
there was a moment of genuine concern
from me when gon powered up his rock
ability that
he was going to actually take bomber's
life and at this point i don't think
gone
has killed anyone gone taking a life is
being pumped up so much now that if
or when and i do suspect that it's a
when he does
i suspect it's going to have to be
highly highly significant
if we look at the way bomber exists and
note that gone is at least as ruthless
as he is
the ability to kill without remorse is a
final stepping stone
or the ability to kill without expecting
remorse from others or the ability to
kill without you know feeling the
remorse that changing the way
others view you that is all gone's final
stepping stone
in fact we come back to the idea of
morality with guarano and kilwa
discussing it kirwan knows what he's
done he's very conscious of the fact
that despite growing up in an assassin
household and being taught the family
business
he's not a good person or at least he's
not able to call himself a good person
because of the things he's done he
doesn't see himself as an innocent
at present gone is an innocent despite
the way he thinks and we have biscuit
and kilwa trying to keep him that way
the fact that kiwa is the one trying to
preserve god's morality is somewhat
heartbreaking because i see cuar
as highly morally insightful in a way
that gone could never be because his
focus isn't on morality but on
fulfilling the tasks
set by his trainers and dad it would
have been a very different situation if
gone had been raised by the zoldic
family
bomber wouldn't be alive now us indeed
let's move on and discuss episode 75
episode 75 and the other players are as
i suspected here to help gotten win the
pub quiz at the end of the game
what would have happened if he hadn't
been able to get that last card well it
looks like all the attention
gone was paying to the game as it
happened all those moments kilwa mocked
him for taking the game seriously paid
off
and good for him goal focus gone that's
what we'll call him i'm really glad we
didn't have to go through all the
questions which was a genuine concern
for me
with takashi's past intense desire for
us to learn what he's learned i
was worried instead we returned to snake
guy who it turns out
is going to help crollow look i said
tagashi was bad at hooking
characters back in less than five
minutes ago i'll give him this
the character is important and i really
should have known that he is capable of
forstalling and getting rid of nen
abilities with the right weird creature
buddy
having caught the bomber i'm i go back
on what i said last episode when i say
last episode i mean the last episode of
hunter hunter not the
five minutes ago i said a thing and i
take it back okay look
i it doesn't happen often but i'll take
it back having called the bomber i'm
excited to see where we go from here
with him but that's
for an arc in the future for now we get
to see if gone actually found his dad
let's talk about that later instead as
we wind down the ark
biski's happy with the kids despite
saying in the beginning that she was
going to mess with them i really don't
understand some of these initial
impressions of characters when i think
about it biscuit clearly likes them and
was never actually awful but creepy kids
sitting on a balcony will always creep
me out there have only been a couple of
characters where this has happened but
while the subverting of expectations is
great and enjoyable it seems odd to me
to subvert them by making them
entirely false i'm not actually sure how
i'm supposed to reconcile the bisky who
appeared in the first episodes of this
arc with the one who exists now
the one now is much more
three-dimensional but she's also only
similar to the original one
in form and i mean for biski even the
form is a little questionable depending
on who's around
we leave biski a character who is alive
for once
alone for now to enjoy her blue chan
blue chan and what i think
is information she's not sharing despite
not knowing what all the plans were to
do with his dad
speaking of jing we learned a lot about
him this episode including that he's
cruel enough to just change someone
else's name to fit with his own interest
but also that he was sentimental enough
to
possibly bring his son to the game he
created it's a sappiness adorable enough
aquila to give heart eyes to
and we saw a lot of kilwa's bashfulness
and hard eyes today
the primary one that got me was his love
for gone shining through as gon walked
away hoping to meet his father but
instead meeting
some more of the designers of greed
island and here i would like to discuss
my theory that tagashi
is dwoon that's it that's my entire
theory tagashi is woun
and the reactions gone has to dwoon and
his environment
are the same reactions takashi would
expect gun to have to his maker
yeah i like that and i'm sticking with
it the fact that jing decided that greed
island would be spelt out using the
names of the 10 people involved in
creating it means a few things
first things first greed island has 11
letters in it so either jing double in
salty gwoon
greed island has 11 letters in it so
either jing double insulted woun or it
doesn't make sense
then we've got the fact that actually we
haven't met anyone with a name starting
with
n which means that the neg that the boys
followed could well be
that person and not jing i also wonder
whether they
have actually left the game at all
because gone was told there was an extra
message that would be given to him once
he'd chosen and taken his cards
there's a great deal of strangeness that
happens when you alter reality by saying
someone can take magical
mechanics from a game to the real world
we have to question reality when magic
is involved and we're supposedly in the
real world now and and there are other
animes entirely based on that concept
and re-zero springs to mind on that but
it's such a strange thing to me the idea
that you can take
something that is a mechanic in a game
that was developed
and put it in the real world doesn't sit
well with me returning to the spelling
of greed island though they haven't met
everyone they've met the greed aspect as
far as we can tell but the island
there's almost half the team missing
i'm very confused with that but i
imagine we're going to meet them in this
upcoming arc
and i have to say i'm very excited to be
getting into a new arc to be back on the
main storyline of questing to find and
be worthy of one's father which is
really the
storyline of the arc that we just
finished but like
less game will we immediately be
sidetracked by crollow being
uncursed and the phantom troop turning
up i have no idea
what exactly will happen to bomber and
the other two no one knows
they'll probably go on bombing or join
the phantom troop which would serve them
well i'm sure
gone and killer are leaving a trail of
people who only half-heartedly want to
kill them in their wake it could turn
into a huge issue
if they full-heartedly decide that they
all want
them dead another thing i noticed in the
art was that compared to when we started
and compared to even the beginning of
this arc gone's face has lengthened and
gained
slightly harder edges now this could
just be the change of
scene but it seems as though gone is
aging up he's maturing and it's being
reflected in his art style here and
there whether by design or by accident
interestingly kiwa's art's not doing
that at all he still seems very young
and soft and doe-eyed her softer more
thoughtful energy
is wonderful but okay right now
i want to see who it is that's fishing
so that's it from me if you enjoyed this
discussion of the end of an arc hit that
like subscribe and whatever
else might be there button come hang out
on the discord and click here here or
here for more
and i'll see you next time